welcome to Batman I'm Batman Kevin Smith
I'm mark barnard a look at where are we
what's this it's a home show man showing
it this is the bar at my house I'm
showing tail being that I'm a STONER
nobody ever uses this bar I know I'm got
my eye on this fancy bottle of comically
all the kind of liquor we have this
fancy comic book the liquor nerd booze
but this is a home show man right then
rather than like go without we said
let's do a show here at home so here we
are this is this is fat man I'm Batman
cash I should probably have a smoking
jacket on it nobody [ __ ] smoking you
can ever wrote
you could be smoked literally I know if
I get it's too far away to reach well
though use the Force loop the last
weekend just hiding bottles of booze and
chandeliers where's this you just need
like a button to like [ __ ] it we had a
desk man that was that show man caves
built and that you press the button on
the desk and eight
popped up like a case and they had put
my dad's urns
my dad's ashes in an urn very small urns
by the size of the bone in there like
you know so hey there your dad's pretty
desk and it was very sweet
I immediately hid my we did we'd would
appear contraband what did they think
you would need to have your father's
ashes on a riser what I think they were
very I was impressive like you I mean in
a desk I was like can you make it drive
but I think I don't know maybe like
Batman II kind of like right there in
the desk that guy that version of Batman
would have just before like it'll be
like half Martha and half Thomas yeah
he'd be surrounded by the edges and then
Robin also just in case good [ __ ] hi
Sam Martha Thomas Robin and a fourth
empty every time Alfred comes in the
room he's always like you know that's
for you right like why must you be some
molded monkeys and then they get drunk
because that's all they did it man
pretty much creepiest stinkiest Batman
of all time not stinkiest being bad he
was great Batman but stink of the booze
I mean no longer with the ginger ale and
the champagne yeah straight up [ __ ]
champagne [ __ ] man like that was one
of my favorite things in comics about
Batman is the idea that like he'll sit
there in front of Jim Gordon in year one
and be like um there's a girl here and
we [ __ ] all night now because and then
there's something about like he doesn't
know it's ginger ale you know just like
he's never [ __ ] why would a guy like
that drink I mean maybe it's pain
medication is he self-medicating himself
alright I'll buy that I buy that but
alcoholic Batman would also be a little
more fun look I mean honestly yeah but
and you would hope well he's just one of
those nasty drugs so is he shut up
you're all punched [ __ ] [ __ ] like
he's got like this would you
he's got the Camelbak full of like vodka
just coming into the helmet hold on a
second
where's my ball where's my wine sack
where's my drinking cow Oh
brings up a Cal that as like to focus
your cans and straws the Governator
shots yeah because of all the [ __ ]
whiskey that you need [ __ ] voice oh I
love my files
wait where's Brigid cow and the booze
cave Oh still happy leave a little wine
in the Sun would you [ __ ] say old man
back bad the drinky use alright let's
talk a measly yeah and today today being
Thursday it happened it happened Emmy
nominations and now jokes I knocked that
flash thing they announced the Emmy nods
now we're marked for those of you who
just tuned in for the first time but
everyone else watches on the regular
nose marks part of the official press
corps May's editor at the LA [ __ ]
time I am they tell us things yeah so
what happened we do have to get up early
on a morning like we used to it used to
be 5:30 Pacific is when they would
announce these things so everybody was
up at the crack of [ __ ] dawn so it
could be 8:30 Eastern Time
okay we've now shifted it to 8:30
Pacific because who wants to get up at
[ __ ] 4:00 a.m. to deal with Emmy
nominations excellent so not crazy
[ __ ] early but early enough to be
like having to pay attention to things
and this is part of your job
I'm the film editor so say like what do
you give a [ __ ] about the enemies other
than like I love TV but like not for
your job or dude for the job but it
becomes an all-hands-on-deck thing at
the times where they flood the newsroom
with staffers and reporters are calling
for comments and everybody's working on
stories and so I was lending a hand to
our TV team is it like spotlight just
not as rapey
it's a hundred percent less rapey I feel
and there's way less children involved
all across the board
well then is it in the spotlight
newsroom well I'm not in the newsroom
but it was kind of all about children
yeah yeah in a bad way
sorry kids yeah journalism
good luck man it's so good they're like
we're gonna give it an it wins
everything give you a Tony it can sing
so you got what uh so even though your
film they're like come on in sir yeah me
so I didn't help us at all are welcome
over children I'll buy you coffee and
also like some people on the list are
from movies so you can be like hey
absolutely Viola Davis is the film
actress thank you very much and a Juris
Alba and Idris Elba and Benedict
Cumberbatch was TV is movies mmm but
it's still TV goes back yeah jaw fluid
now that I'll buy these new celebrities
man they do TV and movies because they
go with the money is back when we were
young you picked one yes
yeah sit on a fence if you graduated you
never went back yeah that's true like if
you were black you were ruined right or
you were you were doing like somebody a
favor and winning an Emmy for it like
Bruce Willis did go on didn't go on
friends I mean yeah I think so
I mean you know Clooney's done that too
but it's been affirmed yeah Clooney
should win everything
there's and he got in training right
there all right man we just lost like
all the Conservatives who watch the show
George holding all right let's talk
Emmys me yes so this year yes Game of
Thrones 23 mm a single man he's all over
there
23 23 most I know the screen is now your
design language as well 23 23 Emmy
nominations including Best Drama Series
writing for drama series directing for a
Drama Series supporting actress Maisie
Williams emilia clarke and lena headey i
don't think there are any lead actors in
this show because it's such a big
ensemble everybody's up for supporting
that's true good point
supporting it but how awkward yes we'll
be in the same
three of the six nominees are all from
the same show who if you had to pick and
this is based on not the season we just
watched but the previous season or the
season we just watch um she washe was
amazed e yams got a big nod and we keep
showing the footage of her yeah Oh
Sophie Turner did not get a nod this
year which is a shame because I thought
it was kind of her you are here for her
yeah kind of her year she got the x-men
she made that movie if you saw it all
right so wait of those three mm-hmm who
had and again like [ __ ] Awards like
doesn't change the fact that they're all
great but of those three if you had to
pick one who gets the trophy we need
pickles as strong as this year um I feel
like Maisie Williams I think gets it
this year
I'm just for me like if I had to pick
Lena Headey feels like her year was last
year which was the you know shaving head
shame walk all that stuff with the cept
and the sparrows and all that [ __ ] those
truth Emilia Clarke had a good year but
every year for her feels like I start
awesome I get a little bit debased and I
[ __ ] in a big bad way and this year
didn't feel any different from the other
years like I did a cool [ __ ] with a
dragon at the end I know it's kind of
what you do that's your jam and they put
it on the boat finally that's that was
the big moment but yeah is it in terms
of again they were all fantastic this
year but Maisie probably had heavier
lifting to do this I'd say her name like
I know it are you yes probably had
heavier lifting to do this season
especially like you know she got the
crap kicked out of her and stuff had it
played blind yeah like a lot of showy
stuff they didn't point to and say oh ya
know she's acting her ass off apologist
give it to one of the other two people
that aren't in game should we look who
any other people supporting actor in a
supporting just go I got lead I got a
lead I'm scrolling down
you're watching [ __ ] happen I was
supporting actor supporting actor in a
movie actress scroll down
drama there we go home shows are always
there little yeah go go to the bathroom
don't even hit pause because we're on
fly Outstanding Supporting Actress in a
Drama Series so Lina had Hedy for Game
of Thrones Emilia Clarke Game of Thrones
Maisie Williams Game of Thrones
Constance Zimmer for unreal
do you have you ever seen unreal I have
seen unreal it's really [ __ ] good
explain it unreal is looking at the sort
of behind the scenes at a fictionalized
version of The Bachelor okay so it's all
about the crazy [ __ ] politics and the
cutthroat imaginations and the evil at
the core of having to create this kind
of particular romantic reality to Munich
or no it's satiric but it's black is sin
like it really is dark which like does
Larry Sanders feel more fun than unreal
yes Wow totally yeah I mean in Larry
Sanders got dark right but at least this
is the started door it starts drying
doesn't really let up all right so
Constance Zimmer is also nominated yes
Maggie Smith for Downton Abbey
- you know it's [ __ ] Mary Smith
forever
it's a Dame Maggie forever and Maura
tyranny the amazing more tyranny who I
love from Newsradio I don't watch the
affair I saw the first half of the first
season but she was really good in it
yeah I mean I'd have no so good that I
was she was so damn good I mean I don't
know if I brought my own baguette stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] why would you cheat on
her you know what I'm saying like Abbey
from ER how dare you that she also
played that but I was like it is Lisa
Miller
radio she's awesome all right but so I
mean it's a good they're all good batch
out of here yeah alright let's go back
to the top and do them all I'm gonna do
them all might as well man lead actor in
a drama bring it Kyle Chandler bloodline
Joe watch it no my wife watch it loved
it yeah how do you say his name Rami
Rami Malek Rami Malek mr. robot
brilliant for sure that performance is
[ __ ] brilliant like if I had to put
odds like he wins this one really yeah
let's go down the rest of the list Bob
Odenkirk better call Saul Bob Odenkirk
always wonderful Matthew Rhys Rhys let's
go with Rhys raise G Americans he's the
guy that's not Felicity he's good you
watch this show I've seen a couple
episodes and he's very watch Liev
Schreiber Ray Ray Ray Ray Ray come on
right ray Donovan
I love this show yeah yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] it's like shot around town so
it's almost like you know travel log to
Los Angeles but I love him i watch him
do anything I always think he should
have been Batman
he's got the badge got the height and
the body for it and [ __ ]
well he was Sabretooth he picked it as
he made his choice I'm sure but Ben
[ __ ] pig dared over once and they
still gave him another shoe let [ __ ]
Liev Schreiber be a hero
radon is an anywho and Kevin Spacey of
course house of cards I'm gonna go with
you man mr. robot kid I think it's like
a good story and these words always love
narratives yeah what's the story there
I think the story is like here's this
little show on USA that nobody really
thought anything of here's an actor
who's Egyptian I believe who yeah who
had always been like tiny bit roles just
doing like I'm sure he's played a
terrorist once or twice because it looks
like that kinda sorta yeah
boilers yeah boy yeah but I feel like
the the super intellectual like super
smart edgy drama on a network that
doesn't ever isn't ever known for that
sort of thing with an actor who's acting
his [ __ ] ass off he's acting the size
of you know and everybody else and not
in an actor II way where you're like ooh
I smell acting no like he's doing a
thing he
and from what I understand the thing
he's doing is far from who is in real
life yeah like that's literally putting
on a character somebody worked on that
shows that that like between takes he
stayed in character listened to that
kind of music and stuff but that it all
pays off and as you see it there on the
screen it's one of the most believable
performances yeah
I've seen in the fiction drama in the
last few years you know Kevin Spacey's
been nominated and won everything else
already anyway we think it's gonna be
Rami
I'm going with Rami Lead Actress in a
Drama Claire Danes homeland I watch it I
dig that show Viola Davis how to get
away with murder my wife watches you do
I watch it yeah she's great she's good
always great taraji P Henson mor of
course
batshit crazy and I love you in the
senior everybody okay Tatiana maslany
orphan black and this is the second year
she's been nice I mean cuz in the
beginning she wasn't like getting
attention no not at all I remember
they're busy cuz she plays nineteen time
acting [ __ ] clinic but yeah just if
you're talking about sheer effort yeah
she wins for doing the most heavy
lifting look I gotta play seven
different distinct characters sometimes
I'll on screen together and make you buy
that they're all different if they win
if she wins they give her they should
give her seven I know a badass bouquet
yes
Keri Russell for the Americans we all
know Felicity yeah and Robin Wright for
house of cards and she's won before
right I think she has yeah who did you
pick out of that groom I pick his Keri
Russell yeah you feel two years I feel
like everyone I feel like a shade much
in the same way that Rami Malek has
never really been recognized for
anything I don't think Keri Russell has
ever been given tons of credit and she
has so much to do on the show has to
play so dark at times instilled and have
that veneer of I'm still a mom
pretending to be American and in a
forced marriage that I don't really want
but I'm kind of falling over this guy
but we're both horrible people like it's
all that's what it's about
yeah it's okay they need to hire you in
the market all you need to do is that ad
and I want to watch that show [ __ ]
years ago
that sounds bad at like Russian spies
who were raised in rose villages in
Russia to pretend to be Mary
then mated with another agent - then
they're forced to [ __ ] yeah of course
like you built a fuss but it's like they
don't love each other but they grow to
love each other yeah I mean then they
have children like they've been on
they've been in country for long enough
to have had children because that's part
of their cover just starting its third
third and last I'm gonna do it I'm doing
diving get in there uh Keri Russell my
back that good I think viola won last
year so I feel okay if she doesn't win
this year right although she Animas
lying
I would love to root like if I gotta
have a dark horse I wanted to be her
Lead Actor in a limited series Bryan
Cranston all the way played LBJ Benedict
Cumberbatch gosh Sherlock the abominable
bride Aegis Albert Luther mm Alice
Cooper Gooding jr. for the People vs Jay
Simpson also Courtney B Vance for the
People vs OJ Simpson and Tom Hiddleston
before the night man it's just aired on
A&E lead actress and a limited series
Kirsten Dunst was in Fargo this season I
had no idea I was really good this year
was really good and she was apparently
good enough together Felicity Huffman an
American crime she lives up the street
from me thankfully Audra McDonald lady
day at Emerson's barn grill that is an
HBO special was it yeah literally it's
like an HBO movie they just make it it
looks great so it gets nominated Sarah
Paulson and the People vs OJ Simpson she
did good job yeah clipper Lili Taylor
for America merican crime is that Lili
Taylor that is Lili Taylor from back in
the day from never good for her man is a
dogfight
right Lily to Kerry Washington for the
confirmation movie the movie about Anita
hill-hill yes okay lead actor in a
comedy got these categories all over so
this is a [ __ ] sitcom a word right
yes not to putting it down but
essentially lead actor in common yeah
there's all half hours Anthony Anderson
for blackish yep
Aziz Ansari for master of none everyone
loved the [ __ ] show it's really good
Will Forte for last man on earth noop
william h Macy also lives up the street
with Felicity Huffman interesting for
shameless Thomas Middleditch isn't
Middleditch little dish with a date with
Abby he's a funny guy I met him in real
life it's he's a funny dude and real
Silicon Valley and Jeffrey Tambor of
course for transparent lead actress in a
comedy jld Ben Louie Louie Dreyfus for
veep she was wonderful to shoot some
that see they had a fantastic season of
that show on veep and that could have
gone either way because they lost their
a show the showrunner the guy that
created and stuff but they were smart
enough to bring on Dave Mandel who also
lives right um what as does Penny
Marshall [ __ ] bill condon his
Hollywood [ __ ] they lost they lost
their man Amelia or mondo initiating
they lost Armando but they gained Dave
Mandel Dave Mandel came in and like I
wrote him I emailed them after there was
an episode I think it was like eight or
nine where they did this documentary
Kathryn her daughter did this
documentary and it was called like
kissing your sister like you know
there's a story of a tie because there's
that tie and this whole season was a
presidential election presidential
election wound up in attack so that
episode after it was done man I wrote
him I was like dude that was one of the
best half hours of [ __ ] television
ever created
it was absolutely [ __ ] brilliant and
he found a way to break format and do
something cool than season 5 of a show
that we all know what it is and stuff
but they broke format but didn't like
alien anybody
that's [ __ ] cool any knees that ain't
easy and she's phenomenal ellie kemper
in the unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt just
funny Tracee Ellis Ross for blackish
Diana's daughter is that right which
means by definition hi you do its I
didn't even if I could know that I'm
totally telling my mom that next time I
talk you will literally start that's
Diana Ross's daughter she'll tell every
bird show Tigers mm-hmm
Laurie Metcalf for getting on that's
right man Laurie Metcalf is on a show on
HBO called get none this is aunt Jackie
from Roseanne one of the greatest
actresses like I think ever on the
planet to be honest with you man she's a
ninja she's she do no wrong
yes and she never like I mean she stands
out and as though she's just wonderful
but like you know she's it's weird that
she doesn't get like bigger gigs
constantly because she's so [ __ ] good
this is how good she is she was in
misery on Broadway with Bruce Willis
that was as a show that lived up to its
title I'm sure if you go and read all
the stories they wrote around the time
that he was in that play he was not
sharp I don't know
read what they wrote I didn't say but
she they said every night was like is
killing it family looks and as anyway
and she had to essentially yeah that's
the role and also since you know you're
not getting help from the other dude you
are the show at that point from all
reports like I she was fantastic I
wanted to go to that show so badly but I
never got to see it but I'm I'll be
honest with you I don't feel like I've
missed out on anything although I would
have liked to have seen her right I've
seen the other guy not act on my set
maybe you just like do one of those like
she's amazing great yeah my holy crap
this is the best play ever I just do
this Shh I don't from what I've read it
you didn't
have to say she talked a lot I dinner
and then he was getting Moses lines you
know Oh being fed to him and stuff but
so that's another thing Laurie Metcalf
is like total theater actors and stuff
like now classically trained
she got to deal with that to have the
patience the tolerance to do that she
deserves she deserves this Emmy for that
performance on Broadway and also a giant
jug of comic the wine no doubt Amy
Schumer for inside Amy Schumer uh-huh
and Lily Tomlin for grace and Frankie Oh
Lily Tomlin got the nod she's amazing
huh but the other one didn't know Jane
Fonda Jane Fonda did not seem to rank
I've seen Gracie Frankie if I had to
pick one I would definitely pick Lily
Tomlin the exam is [ __ ] hysterical
even now like she's like 80 or so yeahi
something she's still firing her also
oh [ __ ] she's hysterical she was in that
movie was a grandmother a grandma that
was and also like Lisa cujo's show web
therapy mm-hmm she did a run as her
mother that was [ __ ] some of the
funny [ __ ] I've ever seen in my life man
is well fairly recent only a couple
years ago but she was absolutely genius
and the premise of that show is like you
know it's basically as if the show was
shot on your webcam because you're doing
web therapy with the doctor so her mom
would get on and Skype with her
essentially her FaceTime and she and
it's [ __ ] just Lily Tomlin facing
camera the whole time doing material
she's unbelievable man and grace and
Frankie that episodes I did watch she
was dynamite man so yay give it up for
her is that for me as a tough race
between Julia Louie Dreyfus
and Lily Tomlin but I've seen every
episode of beat so I got a lean toward
there even I loving I love Amy Schumer I
love all these extras yeah it's hard
it's I didn't know Tracee Ellis Ross was
was related to Diana Ross at all and now
you're voting straight the others rock
I'm gonna write this one in from mom she
loves Diana Ross but that's not Diana
Ross like doesn't matter he's got a heat
wave should we do dry
how many in drama let's do him alright
comedy series blackish master of none
modern family as always Silicon Valley
transparent unbreakable kimmy schmitt
and veep you know I'm a beep fan so I
would say be put you pick I kind of go
either V / master of none
I don't think Aziz Ansari wins best
comedy shot for that drama series the
Americans Americans guilt I love this
yeah the Americans better call Saul AMC
Downton Abbey PBS homeland homeland how
house of cards and mr. robaix for Game
of Thrones and of course Game of Thrones
in the game of Thrones
um let's see I mean [ __ ] out of this
whole list Game of Thrones for me yeah
kinda alright after that would be mr.
robot in a world of no Game of Thrones
that said mr. robot but Game of Thrones
yeah
really strong season but mr. robot [ __ ]
like it I'd give that to the guy that
created like there must be a writing
award of something that show is [ __ ]
dynamite what a rabbit hole you fall
down on that show tonight they started
season two right it just began yeah like
this week I don't know how you follow up
that season one
I don't know parrot own I mean honestly
it's like it would be like is it Fight
Club had a sequel would you know you
look to watch it does now does it really
in comics yeah
Fight Club - from Dark Horse comic
written by Chuck Palahniuk the news what
from the source itself from the source
itself really yeah [ __ ] on the show I'm
gonna [ __ ] on this you should keep that
[ __ ] at the con a mic that's a good idea
man holy crap really look at it I
haven't looked at it yet
I'm sure though don't give us a book if
we want a book no dad he was two books
if we went to book probably we should
get our own copy oh wow
alright so problems outstanding limited
series American crime Fargo the night
manager people versus OJ Simpson :
American crime story and roots whoops
what do you feel
Oh Joe Simpson yeah everything OJ
Simpson is nominated for it's gonna win
this year
because it was that good it was that
good and it was this year's weird
fascination with OJ Simpson is something
of a phenomenon like who [ __ ] knew
that anybody cared this much about OJ
years later for this to do as well as it
did and to be as good as it was and then
ESPN had a documentary actually in
America yeah which is also phenomenal
and also remember they found the knife
this year and they were like a knife but
yeah I get the feeling that that given
where we are also socially and
societally in it feels like that it's
writing a good wave so Cuba Gooding jr.
was nominated was he yelling great he's
good he's not going I think Courtney B
Vance win and I think as Johnnie Cochran
like I think he's the one who gets Best
Lead Actor in a miniseries or whatever
okay TV movie all the way the LBJ thing
confirmation another HBO thing Atlas
Luther Sherlock the abominable bride and
a very Merry Christmas got him every
night but Bill Maher especially I heard
they call it a TV movie but I guess says
the only category they felt they could
put it in I know if I would have called
the movie meet me neither but then again
I wouldn't have called Martian a comedy
but the Golden Globe people did watch
pick man I got no horse in this race you
neither in I feel like all the way I
feel like you know either all the way or
confirmation some highfalutin HBO
telemovie thing will do it they're all
they're all wonderful but no real like
on live I have one yeah that's what I
want yeah maybe very Merry Christmas is
the surprise up so could it be
Outstanding Supporting Actor in a Comedy
Series Oh Louie Anderson four baskets
what's Oh what do we Anderson Louie
Anderson the Louie Anderson Anderson huh
what is that baskets that shows that
Galifianakis as a clown yeah and Louie
Anderson as his transvestite mother I
think I think right on yeah that's for
the Emmys before now I gotta watch it no
I need to know now I got to see Andre
Braugher for Brooklyn nine-nine he
consists of a missile in that show
keegan-michael key key and Peele I don't
quite understand how the person whose
name is first in the title is supporting
actor just saying yeah really
Ty Burrell for Modern Family titus
Burgess for unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
that's the dude yeah
Tony Hale for veep amazing amazing he's
in yoga hosers
I love him he's fantastic I think he's
won before - yes
and then this might be a new one Matt
Walsh Kirby so that's Mike Mike
McLintock with the mustache I'm happy to
see that man I'd have put all the
[ __ ] male cast in those in that
category there was no good see the Sam
Richardson who's that the black guy on
VP that his name yeah my god that dudes
a [ __ ] gene he's great
oh he's wonderful in the show yeah he
definitely should have gotten a [ __ ]
nut I saw Jonah the other day in real
life
Tim Simon's Sam yeah like tall's
[ __ ] and [ __ ] but I was
someplace and I saw him and I [ __ ]
locked eyes like you I said you're
[ __ ] genius I came out because he had
like one of my favorite lines and
[ __ ] TV this year he was that they
ran his character for like Congress and
[ __ ] and so they have footage of him had
an appearance and he's on like his cell
phones handheld and he's just like
they're overhearing your conversation he
goes I'm getting so much [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
and klitz but then all of a sudden you
heard campaign manager go hey you dumb
[ __ ] he comes over he's like they're
[ __ ] kids there and they rack up all
right man yeah [ __ ] him what does that
do Sam Richardson [ __ ] he's so good in
that [ __ ] they did the episode the last
the season finale at one point he's
getting drunk while he's not getting
drunk with Julia Louie drives his
character the president is getting drunk
in the Oval Office and he's sitting
there with her and stuff and he is like
the light shining heart of
that show he's like at one point she's
like I wish I would have won because she
lost because I wish everybody won but
that's his character at one point Sheila
gets up off the castle and they're bound
she goes down to the floor he goes oh we
praying ma'am she was like oh he's so
[ __ ] good he should have gotten okay
but it's not about who didn't get a
knife how do you want to go we'll keep
we'll go a little bit deeper all right
we went low past the tip with the shaft
Outstanding Supporting Actor in a Drama
Series Jonathan banks better call Saul
Peter Dinklage Game of Thrones Ben
Mendelsohn bloodline who is also in the
new Star Wars news yes he's the chief
bad guy mmm Kit Harington Game of
Thrones no Jon Snow
Michael Kelley for house of cards and
Jon Voight for ray Donovan he's
wonderful in that show Outstanding
Supporting Actor in a limited series
Jesse Plemons for Fargo yeah and Boheme
Woodbine for farming I think they missed
a little harder that's the stuff of Ty
Jesse Plemons and Boheme Woodbine from
Fargo yes Hugh Laurie from the night
manager sterling K Brown for the people
vs. absolutely oh [ __ ]
I feel like G faulty what walks away
with that one David Schwimmer
and John Travolta this of Wow everybody
yeah sterling Brown David Schwimmer and
John Travolta everyone talked about John
Travolta's problem yeah Outstanding
Supporting Actress in a comedy
niecy Nash for getting on Alice and
Janie for Mom Kate McKinnon presenting
alive I'd [ __ ] give her a prize right
John being around oh my god she's a
genius
Judith Light for transparent Gaby
Hoffmann for transparent and Anna
Chlumsky for beep I love her on V mmm
yeah I love her on V but I would like
Kate McKinnon is yeah it's like a
McKenna Allison Janney who always wins
these things because it's Allison Janney
but I would say yeah and she's fantastic
- but I would give it to Kate because
you got to do she's so many different
characters on that yeah like that's a
lot of performing man but she's [ __ ]
brilliant okay
the what's this we talked about we
talked about that we talked about that
let's do the guest actress this
to the guests yeah well there's some
guests Outstanding Guest Actor in a
Drama Series Max von Sydow Game of
Thrones and Michael J Fox was on The
Good Wife
Reggie Kathy was on house of cards
harsh Allah Ali house of cards
Paul sparks house when I got I can do
that was easy and Hank Azaria for ray
Donovan good for him man mmm I mean you
know probably max once I know yeah just
by virtue of the fact that was you know
mid eighties give them all the awards
for a few years you know I'm saying this
is a legend for Christ's sakes I know
it's unfair to everyone else's like we
tried are a three-eyed Raven he played a
bird you're not mean the Merciless
everybody else that's true man Clyde to
some people Outstanding Guest Actress in
a comedy series Laurie Metcalf the Big
Bang Theory Christine Baranski
the Big Bang Theory Tina Fey and Amy
Poehler for Saturday Night Live Poehler
Melissa McCarthy presenting I love Amy
Schumer from Zion I live and melora
hardin for transparent that's uh that's
boy everyone it seems like everyone got
a [ __ ] any nod with me you drilled
down deep enough maybe your nominated in
there somewhere maybe i mean how [ __ ]
sad is it that like the emmy nominations
came out and i've even thanked not us
not ever are you wait do they have a
outstanding from the production's line
outstanding narrator outstanding hosts
for reality or reality-competition
program hey Jane Lynch for Hollywood
game night see you were on that show
I mean nominated I made her a better
stronger host by being funnier with
myself
you got a teensy bit of skin and I get a
little feet that's true I get a taste
outstanding production design no we
don't care about that although they're
all winners
casting for drama comedy for limited
choreography cinematography for multi
camera
outstanding cinematography for a
single-camera game
stakes that one Randy had done that's
for a limited movie or TV series out
staying some cheese boy this is deep I
never seen this many categories on the
enemies do they just do a lot of this
off-camera there's a lot of like the
creative arts Emmys where they hire the
pretty lady to give awards to
troglodytes we look at edit base alright
dark rooms doing effects thank you hey
vinyl got a nomination even though they
canceled that show I like that show man
I guess they can't so cuz it was pretty
expensive yeah nobody watched it
outstanding variety talk series yeah
that might have been one that could
count you know the comic book man could
have been up for comedians in cars
getting coffee Jimmy Kimmel Live last
week tonight with John Oliver give that
[ __ ]
all the prizes yeah that shows genius
The Late Late Show with James Corden
Real Time with Bill Maher Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon it's John home
alone the way oh my god that show is
[ __ ] the moat the best show although
I'm also a little chagrined that
Samantha bee did not get any luck yeah
[ __ ] look at this sausage party and
that shows [ __ ] awesome it's you're
really tight I watched that on YouTube
the morning after it airs yes like I
forgot Bill Maher had a television show
Stephen Colbert didn't get nominated no
he's [ __ ] and honestly he's my
favorite late-night knows he's funny
like actually funny legit funny
outstanding variety sketch series
documentary now very [ __ ] super food
oh my god Fred Armisen give him all the
awards drunk history like quite a bit
inside Amy Schumer key and Peele very
funny show they're done now they're done
Portlandia oh my god [ __ ]
competing against some zombie pharmacist
competing against himself documentary
now on Portlandia splitting the vote and
Saturday Night Live which he can also
take claim a little piece so as he was
on an episode last year I guess that's
you know look they're up there online
you can see all these nominations go
check them out for yourself there's a
[ __ ] ton that goes deep man like I'm
still scrolling Kyle Bookman couldn't
get one stunt coordination for a comedy
series a variety program come on man
[ __ ] best hockey jerseys on TV just a
nod I don't have to win I'm sure like a
hockey team might win
Samantha bee got outstanding writing for
a variety series right full frontal
Samantha bee inside Amy Schumer key &
peele last week tonight with John Oliver
he's gonna take all the awards yes
Portlandia and siren and night live yeah
I feel like John Oliver has become the
Jon Stewart of Late Night which is just
if he's nominated he's going to win it
all
yeah and always does as it did he win
last year for a bunch of stuff I think
he did I think you did yeah man that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] dynamite hey Scott
Alexander and Larry karaszewski they did
the People vs OJ Simpson I love The
Hustler movie Oh people of his Larry
flavors Larry Flynt such a great and it
would they did yes also such a great
script
Wow I'm [ __ ] happy for them yeah yeah
well I didn't see them for a little
while so it's nice to see them [ __ ]
getting some attention well deserved
attention um well there it is man lots
of Emmys going to lots of people that
apparently aren't me mmm but all
deserving in various law also very
deserving
yeah we don't do it the TV business to
win Emmys no because we did oh I failed
miserably we do it to be [ __ ] and klitz
I think give that [ __ ] give the
writing prize to veep this year for that
one line eating so much [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] son unbelievably great ah
there it is folks the Emmys your Emmy
nominees not even all of them at [ __ ]
I'm partial list and then we rambled
about a bunch of things and then in
three months we'll talk about the
winners yeah [ __ ] but remember we're
all winners
there's a [ __ ] Senate live sketch
that you can watch like on YouTube where
it's like mother it's like mom's game
show I forget what the actual title is
but Kate McKinnon plays a mother and the
contestants are three kids and all the
questions are about like their lives and
[ __ ] like that and like at one point
that bonus round is she brings in her
husband and it's Bobby Moynihan and
she's like okay bonus round question
with your father and he comes out and
he's all confused looking he goes hey
you kids don't to that and they're like
good that good he's like alright here's
your mother but at the end of it she's
like we're all winners cuz we're all
together like
so they're all winners folks they're all
kids all together come back that's all
we're going to talk about for now
[ __ ] yes go do other things you can
go read the rest of this list which I
assure you will take the rest of your
day its vast thick is a dick doesn't we
like to say big dick long one too
that's it for fat man I'm Batman this
week now I've been Kevin Smith I'm mark
Bernard come back next week same that
time or next episode even same
bat-channel that be smart cast doctor no
that be what would be it would be
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith or worse
I'm cast calm I knew I was close we got
this it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder